[Music]
good so you're live now on the kirkman
the hand show uh nice to meet you
normally normally i said this earlier i
am podcast wonderful but i'm gonna i'm
gonna hand that over to you today out of
respect i think you've earned that
you've earned that right either that or
pay me a royalty what do you want to do
oh i would love to pay the royalty i
would love to negotiate that i want uh
one dollar a mic until fifty thousand
mics sold and we'll call it a day
that's why they call me mr wonderful
really
so explain to me how so
just how the show works and i'm a huge
fan of the show
and of you you're my favorite shark by
far how are you guys going to pull off a
live uh edition of the show because i
would imagine the the the average
pitches takes forever no yeah you've
nailed it that's going to be the big
issue so
you know the key to this is to realize
in a pitch now in a live show you're
probably going to get about eight
minutes
normally a shark tank pitch
is about 45 minutes to an hour and 10
and then it gets edited down to eight
minutes right so these contestants
are coming into a whole different format
which i think is going to be really
interesting we've been rehearsing it and
what i love about it it's just sheer
chaos because you're on live tv you got
a hundred million eyeballs including
syndication
don't screw it up because there's no way
to edit it you screw it up sorry it's
over and so i i look at it and say this
is going to be the toughest pitch
they've ever done in their lives and no
matter how many times you rehearse this
stuff because i've seen this happen for
14 years on shark tank you're sitting in
front of a mirror for months getting
ready for your big moment
but this is a whole different deal i
mean you're going to walk out there 26
cameras a live audience
i think the shit's going to hit the fan
i think this is going to be fantastic tv
what is the longest
if you if you may know this what is the
longest pitch you guys ever had to sit
through has there been one that's been
three hours two four hours no no the
longest pitch was one hour and 43
minutes by a real [ __ ]
and
you know
it's so frustrating just brutal but
the product had merit that guy was an
idiot so that was the problem which one
was this
i assume it made air it was a it was a
product called toppers and it was
basically a very simple idea you know
you finish your meal your your steaks
half eaten yup and you want to stick it
in the fridge till tomorrow which is
what every millennial is doing you know
in their condo particularly during the
pandemic right this guy had designed a
vacuum sealed topper you just stick
right on the plate it fit ninety percent
of your plates yeah and it was a great
idea and he had a huge order from
walmart just a huge order but his
valuation was just stupid it was just
stupid because at the end of the day
it's going to get knocked off and you
know it's not high-tech it's just a
piece of plastic it sits on a plate but
it was a good idea and that's what we
find in shark tank you know you just
don't know what's going to walk through
that door you have no idea we don't get
to see it beforehand we have no idea
what's going to walk through there we're
in discovery like you are as the
audience and sometimes the craziest
ideas make hundreds of millions of
dollars sure do you do you get as angry
i know you do you i mean i get now i am
very into the show i get very angry so
when somebody comes in the music starts
playing i'm all excited i'm watching
with my with harry minahan my son
there's a huge fan a huge fan of yours
he's he's 10 years old
um
he doesn't swear but he wants to be able
to swear so give the impression of you
calling manish an [ __ ] and telling
him [ __ ] you he loved that that's one of
his favorite moments i don't say that on
live tv that's not family values i
understand that but you did say it to
him on the episode so i appreciate that
but he's not saying oh that they believe
they beat that well that guy was a total
dick 100
moment that was that was one that was
one of your best moments of all time
though and you said you're an [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here great moment
right i did say that yes i did say that
and all of it was true he was an [ __ ]
and he should bring the [ __ ] out of
there i agree
when somebody rolls in there though and
i'm watching and the guy comes in or the
woman comes in or the couple comes in
and they say hey sharks i'm whatever
we're from wherever greenville ohio we
have this company and we want uh eight
hundred thousand dollars for two percent
of the company
get the [ __ ] out of here with that like
at that point in your mind you are you
already
crossing them off or are you thinking
do you still have an open mind or does
your mind close immediately when that
happens so here's the here's the risk
they've got if they're asking for eight
hundred thousand dollars we have no
choice but to give them eight hundred
thousand dollars now if the company's
doing 10 million in sales or 20 million
sales there's room to negotiate so you
can't go you so kevin you can't go lower
than that you can't no no that's the
that's the platform rule and it's been
in place for 14 years and that makes the
entrepreneur really think through
that negotiation and have a plan ahead
of time i've invested way more than 800
000 in deals but they're real companies
that they basically have sales and and i
don't have a problem doing that but if
you have no sales it's just an idea and
you think it's with 800 000 cash you're
screwed no one's going to do that with
you
right what's the what's the
overall i saw somebody ask cuban this on
one of these youtube shows
overall would you say you're in total
investments are you up are you down
do you have any idea yeah no i believe
me i track it so you know we've we have
a whole team that manages this portfolio
of over 57 private companies and here's
the thing we've all learned on shark
tank okay we're in the middle of season
14 right now i'm going to be shooting
next week back in la i don't know what
i'm going to see but it's going to be
amazing because each year the deal size
gets bigger because people really want
to tap into that massive social media
platform you know 100 million plus
eyeballs when you go through syndication
eight minutes of prime time television
to third of the country that's pretty
powerful in terms of getting a product
out there and it reduces customer
acquisition cost a lot but whatever i
think is the hot deal of the season
whatever i think is the number one
winner that i bought and i put 300 400
000 into whatever that's never the one
that makes me back my money i wait two
or three years later and it's some crazy
piece of crap product that i thought was
just a joke that ends up being a monster
and i'll give you an example just this
year there was a deal a few years ago
called base paws
cat dna i remember this yes you stick a
swab up your cat's ass and you send it
in and
it and it tells you you know what to
feed it so you can extend its life by 30
what a stupid idea you can buy a new cat
for five bucks why would you pay 29 for
a dna test
so
i bought into it because it was so crazy
so dumb so stupid i thought the company
just sold for over 50 million cash last
month jesus because who knew that pet
dna is smoking hot there's 110 million
cats in america and the entrepreneur the
woman was spectacular in building up
this business she got bought out by a
biotech company that wanted to have her
database of dna and it turns out that
millions of people pay 29 bucks to
extend their cat's life that i'm not one
of them but who cares it was a fantastic
investment my point is you just don't
know
so you need diversification and how you
spread your bets out there uh so i'm a
huge fan of the show i i like personally
and maybe i'm in the minority i don't
know i like when it's just the sharks to
me
i don't need the a-rod i don't need the
gwyneth paltrow i like when this am i do
you do you understand where i'm i'm in
the watch i'll watch for shirks i like
it but
i like the the sharks are you barbara
you guys are my family i don't need
gwendoth paltrow coming in and taking
robert's spot i get upset
so you know
the whole idea of a show that's lasted
14 years which is unprecedented on
television that's like one percent of
shows made you got to hand it to the
producers for disney abc mark burnett
sony all this the alchemy of all these
people coming together and then the
original sharks
but the challenge we have is sharks when
you get a guest shark on you and i used
to care about this i don't anymore you
want to be nice to them they're guests
they're sitting there you're trying to
help them out on their first deal now i
don't give a [ __ ] about any of that if
they can't handle it if they can't
handle it screw them i'll eat them alive
anyways i don't care because you yeah
you gotta change it yeah you gotta treat
gwyneth paltrow like she's barbara right
like it's you're you're she's on the
show so if she's on the show you gotta
treat her that way
listen i welcome her like anybody else
but i'm gonna eat her alive so she
better get ready for that who who is the
uh
who is the so i think the other thing i
like about the show is it does seem like
i'm sure it's not this agreement you
guys had but everybody is comfortable
breaking each other's balls you can kind
of dump on each other but it's in a good
nature way has there ever been anybody
in the show
of the core group that took a while for
them to understand that or was it kind
of good from the get-go
you know this is one of those classic
situations where we don't love each
other as much as we used to i mean you
know we spend more time together than we
do with our own families by the time
this thing is over at the end of the day
we're we're competitors we respect each
other you have to respect the fact that
everybody there is a self-made
millionaire billionaire whatever it is
they did it on their own in different
sectors of the economy so i respect that
we don't have to be friends we don't
have to do another dinner together we
did it for 14 years already so
no social relationship with any of them
off there oh no no listen every time in
new york i go to barbara's place she
cooks me dinner that's what happens i'm
happy to do that we're friends okay but
when we're in that moment of competition
you know here's what happens we've been
doing this for so long we don't see the
cameras anymore we're we're back in the
shark tank we're doing business we have
millions of dollars to put to work we
want the winner deals and we're willing
to compete and so look sometimes if it's
clear to me that i can't get the deal
myself i'm going to cut a deal with mark
or somebody else because we're bidding
the price up we're better to go in
together than we are to go crazy and
drive the price up sometimes that's not
the case sometimes the entrepreneur as
you say know us like family they know
which shark they want and so they they
hone in on that shark and see if they
can kind of deal it's all over the map
on this stuff which i think makes the
show so compelling i mean you just don't
know what's gonna happen and though we
start our day at five in the morning and
by the time we get back to the hotel at
eight or nine at night we're like that's
hard work man that's right and we get up
at five o'clock and do it again so it it
i admire the whole team with 250 people
that put the show together we are like a
family i mean mindy casting the woman
who cast every deal since the beginning
of time i don't even know her second
name i know her as mindy casting and she
has she has looked at hundreds of
thousands of deals and chose which ones
go on shark tank so there you have it
well forget i um congratulations i was
250 people but the only person that
matters right now is you because i'm
talking to you you're mr wonderful and
this is why i respect the royalty thing
so much because what you're saying
to the entrepreneur is well do you
believe in yourself because you believe
in yourself the royalties the royalty is
an easy deal
yeah of course but the royalty is about
return of capital we don't all agree on
deal structure but america has learned
as we as sharks have done over the
decades that there's all kinds of
different ways to structure a deal you
can do debt you can do venture capital
in straight equity you can put a warrant
on it you can put a preference share you
can do all kinds of structure in the
beginning we never talked about that now
we do very complex deals america has
followed us i care about return of
capital first not return on capital if i
never get my money back in a private
deal what's the point of doing it so my
structures tend to involve royalties but
i'll tell you one thing that everybody's
figured out
i'm a unique investor i've got millions
of followers on social media when i back
a product and put it out there on all my
platforms i can drive customer
acquisitions costs down to zero most
companies got a business within 18
months because they're never able to get
their customer acquisition costs online
below the lifetime value of the customer
a fancy way of saying they go bankrupt
advertising i changed that metric i'm
able to get out there with my team and
tell you the story of this product this
company this entrepreneur and change the
whole dynamic of the business now i
don't do that for free if you want mr
wonderful you're going to pay for it
that's how it works
if you had made a deal that the ring
people had wanted how much money would
you have made
oh
don't make me sick i mean you know i'm
sorry now listen having said all that
jamie and i are now friends we host a
dinner every july 5th
in nantucket where we get our families
together our friends and we celebrate
what we both created together but he
should have taken my six hundred
thousand dollars i would i would have
made about 300 million on that deal
is that true
yeah yeah because remember my deal was
debt and warrants i was going to get
equity and the secret sauce to my equity
it couldn't be deluded because he kept
raising money but i was going to keep my
points no matter what happened but he
was a greedy pig and he didn't listen to
me and look what happened he sold the
business for 1.1 billion but jesus
listen i'm willing to make amends and so
we're friends that's good mike do you
have any questions for mr wonder i do i
because you were talking about uh
confidence earlier and the one thing
that bothers me when i watch shark tank
is every once in a while you guys get uh
someone that at the end of their pitch
maybe it's not going well or whatever
and they break down and cry and talk
about how hard they've worked and
everything like that well mr wonderful
by the way is a is a sneaky crier he can
cry he's like meryl streep he can cry on
command yeah sometimes too and that's
one thing wonderful i call him you
you're the top crier on tv today i think
and i just think
i'm not heartless i i sometimes i really
get moved you know i get caught up in
the story remember i don't see the
cameras anymore i'm just sitting in my
seat listening to the pitch yeah the
thing is if you can't get through the
tank if you're going to break down and
start crying you're [ __ ] because the
real world is going to be what you're
saying that's such a lot that's such a
hard answer for me there's no it's true
one of the worst public speakers i've
ever looked at watched in my life all
right and he's a billionaire obviously
facebook everything metaverse like he's
a dummy he couldn't walk through the
shark tank you get eaten alive there's
so many of these entrepreneurs that in
the conference room
are just idiots and sound like [ __ ]
myself included but then sure about you
money for sure it could absolutely make
you that's a daunting experience you
know the way you got to look at it is
money has no emotions it doesn't care if
you cry it goes to the path of least
resistance
it can't stand weakness because it means
uncertainty so all of a sudden all you
can do is say please please give me
money and you start crying why would i
ever do that
that's nuts
do you find it do you find that that
does it annoy you at all when somebody
comes in and you know they're targeting
cuban or lori or somebody or do you not
care
no i don't care i mean look there's only
one mr wonderful damn right
on that you know and that's the bottom
line i mean you know
everybody asks me who's your favorite
shark i say mr wonderful it's the only
guy i want to do business with he's
fantastic well who's your second
favorite shark mr wonderful yeah that's
fair that's fair who's your least
favorite shark oh come on i mean
you know i don't want to say but
i got to tell you
no i won't say
have you picked up on the fact that
contestant's least favorite shark is
robert like no this is mrs mike's theory
he will offer them the world and they're
like i mean what is mr wonderful or cube
enough to say like i don't really care
it does get very annoyed though i like
robert yeah look it's you really have to
understand what the way the chemistry
works is
we're just in the moment i mean we're
just in the moment it's it's not years
and years and years ago you know i don't
know 12 years ago when shark tank you
know for the first three years disney
there's an oh there's a story about this
iger bob iger was the ceo
of disney that owned abc and here's what
i heard through the grapevine because i
i will obey is his wife and william
broadcaster yeah yeah broadcaster focus
on business okay so the story i heard
and i believe it to be true is in season
three when they canceled it they said
okay shark snake shark tags not working
let's cancel it
bob goes home talks to willow and says
we're gonna cancel that show shark tank
she says no you're not
our kids love that show it's family
values it's about business they're
learning something get back on the phone
and put it back on there and i'm sure
that's exactly what happened because out
of the blue i got a phone call from mark
burnett and he says you're back i said
really how that happens it doesn't
matter get your ass to los angeles and
so
that kind of thing that folklore usually
is true with the smoke this fire because
she basically understood what was
starting to happen in america because we
were going through the 2008 recession
and people started to believe in
themselves as entrepreneurs she caught
the wave the next season we exploded we
had tens of millions of people watching
us and that's remarkable and it's never
stopped i mean each year and in 42
countries i was in switzerland the other
day my stepfather lives in geneva and i
got on a train to go to zurich because i
was going to fly to abu dhabi and on
this train this couple comes up to me
and says
are you the guy on shark tank i said
yeah
and they said you're the most hated man
in austria i said what
yeah you're so mean i said well what are
you talking about i don't even know that
they're showing the tape in austria and
she says we're just getting married
we're on our way to zermatt can we take
a picture with you i said sure but i'm
the most hated guy says hey just take
the shot so it was really interesting to
see how global the platform has become
the american tape going all around the
world we're number one in dubai on
friday nights who knew
well now you guys are all sharks you all
have deals with abc
do you make more money or less money
that you guys negotiate together how
does the pay i know you're all executive
producers how does the payment work how
much do you make a year on that show how
much the other it's not that's my you
know how much everyone's making yeah i
know but it's it's not the payment per
app that's not this is a different kind
of show because here you are
as a venture capitalist we were all
investors before we started shark tank
the hardest challenge we had was deal
flow so there's two things to understand
that why that that scene on shark tank's
so powerful powerful for an investor
because every guy in his dog wants to
get on shark tank now everybody
you can't believe the number of
celebrities that i get emails from
saying listen i want to be a guest shark
next year i mean it okay great but the
bottom line is i have 100 million
eyeballs watching my products and
services i've got money to invest
their consumer goods and services very
often we get all our money back the
night it airs okay because people love
the product so much and the secret which
nobody talks about but this is my metric
when i
i'm doing a deal on shark tank and we're
shooting it we're in our 45th minute the
pitch is over
and let's say i did the deal and i
watched the cast and crew
steal all the product come running up
and grab it
i got a winner right there
right there because if all the samples
get scooped up like they come running
onto the set you know they say cut
and it's all gone
winner winner chicken dinner right there
and that's the worst how i do it what's
the worst product you've ever seen get a
deal on shark tank
this woman came out once and uh
said she sang to a five gallon uh
container you know like a water cooler
container and she puts it in a tent in
the in her backyard
and
she spends 20 minutes singing to it in
the tent and it separates into three
separate elixirs
one
that reduces jealousy to one that helps
you fall in love and the bottom third
makes you rich she said she sold it
online for 25 dollars in a tiny vial
that you put around your neck like you
know jolie had blood and her thing and
all that kind of crap so
that sounded so stupid i mean just
unbelievable and so i of course
said that's stupid she said oh yeah if i
was 110 years ago and i came out here
and i had some molasses i poured cocaine
in it and put it in a bottle would you
invest in it i said no that's ridiculous
she said that's coca-cola bozo so you
just never know
what you got now i don't think selling
bs elixirs to people is even legal so of
course i didn't invest in that but
that's the kind of stuff that you got to
keep your ear open to because you don't
know i remember laurie with that piece
of crap sponge it's a smiley daddy or um
her and said do not invest in this this
is a piece of [ __ ] you got to be out of
your mind she said no it's not a piece
of [ __ ] i'm going to sell a ton of it
50 million dollars later
so i buy a lot of plastic crap too now
what's the um what's the current
relationship between you and mark cuban
yeah i don't see you guys interact much
during the show and you kind of seem
like i don't know about you mike they
seem like the two alphas on the show
without a doubt it feels like there's a
not a rivalry but i'm not sure what's
the current state of the relationship
you know we have many deals together i
have a lot of respect for i have a lot
of respect for mark we don't agree on
anything and that's okay because we
don't do structures the same way but we
get the same number of deals done we
there's a deal i'm working on right now
with mark that we're going to go into
together on because he imagine you've
got an mba owner
that has a whole different channel of
distribution and there's then there's
the channels i have i'm in every retail
store in america and overseas as well we
both have powerful channels of
distribution sometimes on a deal it's
better to work together
because particularly you know mark and i
looked at many different beverage deals
wine deals things like that because
i'm willing i'm not a greedy guy if i
think i can make something 10x with mark
or with lori or with damon i've done
deals with everybody barbara
if we think we can work together and
enhance our probability of success we're
going to do it we're not stupid and we
have so many deals i mean
no one deal is going to make or break me
anymore i've got a massive portfolio of
companies and each year and i'll tell
you what's interesting
even today this happened today every
morning i get a call of total
catastrophe from one of my companies oh
we're going bankrupt we're getting sued
i'm going out of business please help me
yada yada yada it's just
brutal and 15 minutes later i get a
phone call like baseball saying we're
going to get acquired for 55 million
bucks
same hour so it's like a passion play of
stuff rolling out every day i've gotten
used to the idea that this is a
portfolio
of just random outcomes you just don't
know what's going to happen and you've
got to just realize
good bad and ugly poopoo happens that's
what occurs here but you stay the course
do the deals find the best entrepreneurs
back them up and one other thing i'll
add which is really remarkable over this
14 years 75 of my returns have come from
the companies run by women and look i
don't want to start you know gender
warfare with a statement like this i
give money to a goat if i get a return
but
women kill it on those shark tank deals
let that base pause deal that was anna
that's a woman right blue land that's
another woman sarah these women are
killers you know that old adage you want
something done give it to a busy mother
right your cupcake company right
oh killed it we just sold it to hickory
farms killed it killed it i mean that
was the best return in shark tank
history i got my money back in three
weeks and it never stopped selling for
years it was incredible
it's been years now it's been
i think tv shows they tease like sam and
diane you remember jim and pam you and
barbara had that kiss a few years ago
are we going to have another passionate
kiss between you two this year that will
get people i think erotic and fired up
all over america again can you promise
that this year
i can't do it it took me 36 months to
come back from being a piece of stone
remember
[Laughter]
uh so so friday so what three weeks from
is that right when's the date dave the
season premiere it is friday september
23rd friday september 23rd so find one
before we let you go so
how so you tape all your episodes you
guys take like five or six in the day
two in the day oh no no no no one in a
day we've done as many as 14 in a day it
takes a day and a half
not episodes remember remember a picture
yeah you gotta when you we try and do 12
pitches in a day but you just don't know
what's going to happen so you've got all
these people from all around america
that flown in there's because of covet
protocols they're sequestered in a motel
they can't go outside they're waiting
their big day comes they get onto the
lot so let's say six of those deals are
sitting in the morning after lunch
another six deals and then we start but
we don't know what's going to happen
some pitch may last 20 minutes won't
last two hours you just don't know and
the last guy may get bumped to the next
day so he just because after you know
after eight o'clock we're like god we're
done we're cooked we've been awake since
and the women have to come in for hair
and makeup at you know five in the
morning four in the morning i don't have
a hair problem here so i can come in a
little later so you know that's how it
is but that takes time too but then
there's the pitches so we try and do the
whole thing and we have a guest shark
they may be here for a day or two we try
and do all their pitches because if
we're going to get a guest shark that's
big in clothing or in makeup or
something like that they're probably
going to see a bunch of makeup deals in
that because it kind of ties to them but
you just don't know and so every day is
completely random and then at the end of
the day even though we've had a wicked
fight
you know
i'll say okay where's dinner and we'll
all end up at avra or something outside
on a round table and have dinner and
then go to bed i mean we hit la every
night it's a lot of fun
so sorry so september 23rd season 14 of
shark tank premieres kev uh kevin
o'leary mr wonderful release the heart
and soul of it really is the hearts off
television today is my favorite tv
character today the great mr wonderful
kevin o'leary hopefully we can come back
and we'll talk to you again okay thank
you take care guys all right kevin good
talking to you it is really like the
number one show i could think of that
like like kids and parents watch
together what else is the best family
stranger things i think is one of those
shows like it's i'm not saying obviously
it's different content but it's like it
is tgif now yeah it's yeah that's and
there's no like there's no sitcom or
family friendly show that people not
that sit down and watch anymore nothing
i know about i kind of watched like
family matters or whatever with my
parents not really yeah
really but i watched tgif i think with
my
mom and brother yeah right yeah but
that's it's just interesting how like it
is he's right like it is a business show
you're learning things at a young age on
it and he's like by the way he's now
like susie ormond like he's like he is
the personal finance guy
of oh he's playing the great the world
like unbelievably well played great if
you like that video wait did you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe